siempre que estés trabajando en física
vas a oír mucho los términos fuerzas
balanceadas y desbalanceadas lo que
quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es ver
distintas situaciones y ver si las
fuerzas que se presentan son balanceadas
o desbalanceadas así que empezamos
viendo el caso en que digamos que está
el suelo que ya tiene en el suelo y
digamos que tenemos una piedra aquí muy
bien entonces aquí tenemos una piedra
quizás es muy grande y digamos que esta
piedra por efecto de la fuerza de
gravedad se está digamos tiene una
fuerza que va hacia el centro de la
tierra de 5 newtons ok entonces esta
piedra que tiene una que más bien que la
gravedad le está ejerciendo una fuerza
de 5 newtons así hacia el centro de la
tierra provoca también que el suelo
imprima una fuerza la fuerza normal en
dirección contraria de 5 newtons muy
bien entonces ese va a ser nuestro
primer escenario digamos que ahora
tenemos una piedra muy similar o de
hecho va a ser exactamente la misma
piedra pensemos que esta es exactamente
la misma piedra para que tengan la misma
masa y nuevamente tiene o está siendo
influenciada por la fuerza de gravedad
que va hacia el centro de la tierra es
de 5 newtons y el suelo le imprime una
fuerza normal también de 5 newtons ahora
imaginemos que tenemos algún personaje
por aquí digamos algún joven fuerte y
atlético que está tratando de empujar
esta piedra aunque ya lo mejor es parte
de su entrenamiento que sabe quién sabe
y digamos que le imprime una fuerza de 2
newtons hacia la derecha sin embargo
esta es esta piedra a la hora de
intentar moverla también genera una
fuerza de fricción y digamos que esa
fuerza de fricción es de 2 newtons pero
en dirección contraria el movimiento muy
bien vamos a ver un tercer escenario una
tercera situación nuevamente tenemos
esta misma piedra aunque ella y tienen
esa misma piedra y ahora tenemos a un
joven mucho más fuerte que es más hasta
se ve que está haciendo mucho más
ejercicio y bueno nuevamente la piedra
está siendo influenciada por la gravedad
y tiene una una fuerza hacia abajo hacia
el centro de la tierra de 5 newtons
tiene una fuerza normal hacia arriba de
5 newtons digamos que la fuerza de
fricción debido al movimiento que le
imprime este joven es
nuevamente de 2 newtons y que esté este
joven le imprime una fuerza de 3 newtons
hacia la derecha muy bien entonces esta
es nuestra tercera situación vamos a
pensar en alguna otra digamos ahora que
aquí nuevamente está el suelo y que
nuestra piedra por alguna razón está en
el aire kate no sé quizás alguien la
agarro bueno de hecho es una piedra muy
grande verdad sí sí pensamos en este en
estas personas digamos que no sé no sé
por algunas razones está en el aire y
nuevamente por la fuerza de gravedad
esta tiene una fuerza hacia el centro de
la tierra de 5 newtons por supuesto como
no está en el suelo entonces no va a
haber una fuerza normal pero digamos que
las partículas de aire ofrecen una
resistencia aunque sea muy pequeña
digamos que ofrecen cierta resistencia
al movimiento de la piedra de uno
newton en dirección contraria al
movimiento ok
y pensemos en alguna última
circunstancia digamos nuevamente que
tenemos el suelo tenemos nuestra misma
piedra ok y por lo mismo tenemos la
fuerza de gravedad hacia abajo de 5
newtons y tenemos una fuerza normal de 5
newtons hacia arriba muy bien ahora
digamos que tenemos como una competencia
entre dos personajes puede ser
un chavo digamos que que otra vez está
empujando esta piedra hacia la derecha y
ahora le imprime una fuerza de 4 newtons
pero está compitiendo a lo mejor con su
hermano menor vamos a poner alguien aquí
mucho más chico
y esta este este niño a lo mejor está
imprimiendo una fuerza de 3 newtons si
sumamos ya la fricción verdad porque la
fricción va en contra del movimiento
entonces digamos que la fricción más la
fuerza de este niño que terminan siendo
de 3 newtons hacia la izquierda entonces
en ese momento quiero que hagas una
pausa y pienses cuáles de estas
situaciones son corresponden a fuerzas
que están balanceadas y cuáles a fuerzas
que están desbalanceadas
aunque ya entonces suponiendo que ya
terminamos de analizar eso vamos a ver
el primer caso tenemos nuestra piedra
que está completamente en reposo y
porque está en reposo pues porque
tenemos la fuerza de atracción hacia el
centro de la tierra que la gravedad de 5
newtons hacia el centro y la fuerza
normal que genera está en el suelo de 5
newtons hacia arriba entonces si nos
damos cuenta la que va hacia abajo y la
que va hacia arriba se cancela en verdad
son son de la misma magnitud y en
directo en sentidos opuestos entonces en
este primer caso corresponde a fuerzas
balanceadas a que corresponde el segundo
caso bueno aquí tenemos este a este
joven que a lo mejor no es muy éste no
es muy fuerte y de hecho no supera la
fuerza de fricción verdad entonces tanto
como empuja hacia la derecha es también
la fuerza que le imprime la fricción en
sentido contrario entonces en la
dirección horizontal se cancela en
verdad bien y en esa dirección están
balanceadas
mientras que la fuerza de gravedad se
balancea también con la fuerza normal
que imprime el suelo
entonces si nos damos cuenta todas estas
fuerzas nuevamente vuelven a estar
balanceadas y eso implica que por bueno
que sí que si este joven sigue empujando
con la misma fuerza pues no va a mover
esta piedra no va a provocar una
aceleración vamos a ver el tercer caso
en donde tenemos a un chico mucho más
más digamos más fuerte porque por
supuesto nuevamente la fuerza de
gravedad y la fuerza normal se balancean
verdad tienen la misma en la misma
dirección pero son de sentidos
contrarios y tienen la misma magnitud
entonces ahora este joven imprime una
fuerza de 3 newtons hacia la derecha
mientras que la fricción imprime una
fuerza de 2 mil newtons hacia la
izquierda entonces qué es lo que nos
queda que tenemos una fuerza neta hacia
la derecha
newton verdad y por lo tanto esta piedra
si se va a mover hacia la derecha
y bueno entonces estas fuerzas son
desbalanceadas vamos a ver el cuarto
caso el cuarto caso tenemos ahora una
piedra que no se encuentra en el suelo
pero si se ve afectada por la fuerza de
gravedad mientras que también se ve
afectada por la resistencia del aire que
desde un newton hacia arriba entonces
esto de aquí corresponde a la
resistencia del aire resistencia del
aire
quizás aquí deberíamos especificar
verdad esta correspondía a la fricción
a la fricción y está también está
también corresponde a la fricción pero
bueno en estos casos ya los analizamos
ahora bien
cuando queremos hacer el análisis de
esta piedra simplemente nos damos cuenta
que son las dos únicas fuerzas que están
aquí interactuando sobre este cuerpo y
que si nos damos cuenta tendremos una
fuerza neta hacia abajo de 4 newtons 4
newtons 5 hacia abajo y 1 hacia arriba
nos dan 4 newtons hacia abajo entonces
está en en este caso tenemos que las
fuerzas no son balanceadas de hecho hay
una fuerza neta de 4 newtons hacia abajo
en el último caso tenemos esta
competencia entre dos entre dos chicos y
donde la fuerza de gravedad si se
balancea con la fuerza normal eso es el
mismo caso que en los anteriores sin
embargo aquí la fuerza que imprime este
chico es de 4 newtons mientras que el de
este puede ser niño es de 3 minutos ya
con la fricción entonces de foro es la
fuerza neta que tenemos es de un newton
a la derecha así que en este caso si se
provoca una aceleración
en más hacia la derecha y más le vale a
este niño quitarse antes de que la
piedra lo aplaste